THANK YOU RESSWOMAN, FOR ME.
SO, A GROU FE BLOCRATI
RILLIOUCREN NO TAX
PAAGT COMES BEFORE YOU
IN THE HOUSE?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK FROM WHAT
WE'VE SEEN SO Y
THE LACK OE AC
WELL, I THINK ADDING TO THSEVERA
SCALT WE'RE SEEING,
DOUBT IT FRANKLYT  THAT PROPOSA.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
COMMUN L
1.7 TRIL
THIS IAB OVERA
A VE, VET Y.EARS, WHICH IS
IT'S NOT GOING T
IN THIS, F UNION JOBST WE
IT'S NOT RLY TO VE
CLOSER TOUR S WHICH ARANT AT TH.
HAVE THREE VOTES TO SP
SOF THCOS
YO IF DEMOIC LEADERS COMTHE BES
WOULOWPROGRESSIVES
THIS>> WELL, I THINK THE THING
THISE BEST THAT WE
HINK THAT
TALK ABOUT T
C AGENDA FOR VERY, REANSE BLOCKS
DON'T THINK HOLD OF WATER.
AND FOR FOLKS SAYINGE ARE G TO
I K  TO START
ASKI S THESEEMRSHEG 60ES.E TEN
WE'RE GOING TO GET SUPPORT FORT
THATSNY HOLD
WATER, PARTICULARL WE
CAT  TEN SENATORS TO SUPPORCOMM.
IT'S AN ARGUMENT --
>>N THISR BILL
THEY HAVE FIVE AND, YOU KNOW
P,
THEY CLD
SOUST ON INFCTURE.HINK THETION
WHICH IS DO WE SE FOR MUCH
LESS AND AN INFRASTRUCTURE
EE
Y REPUBLICANS IN ORDER GETTES?
ORE REALLY TRANSFORM
COUNTRY, CREATE LLIONS OF JOBS,
PEOPLE'S BRIDGESIXED
AND SCHOOLS OREMOCRATIC VOTES?
MAKE HERE IS IT'S GOIN
ALONE IF WE CA MORE FOR PEOPLE H
THE POTENTIAL TO LOWER THEARE
GUARANTEED TO THEIR RIGHT TO
HEALAR OPPOSED TOU
OW60 WDO V
E, AND THEPE O
BLOCKED IN THE SENATT NOW,ECIFIC
AND THAT IIGHTS.
YOU
PAVOTING RIGHTS N.
MARCH.
SENATE DEMOCRATS CAN'T FORCE A A
SENCHIN DOESN'T
SUPPORT THAT PARTICULAR BILL.
HELST SUPPORT WHAT
YOU'REUG I
E FILIER O VO LISTEN TO
AT YOU SAID ABOUT
L K.S UP
LOBBYISTS AND DARK
D RECKONK THATPROBABLYT AS
PART OMANCHIN' WTO THI
ARGUMENT, I GOT TO TELL YOU, I
DON'T .T  BY
L DONATIONS FLTS
>>L, YOU I THINK THAT,ATHET
ABOUT VOTI R WE'RE NOT
TELLINE
1  VOTFORMS.
INFLUENCE OF BIGTHAT NOTT
PARTY, BUT BH PARTIES IN THE
UNTATES CONGRESS.
Y OF POLITICS HASO
N JOE S
NG AND W HNAVIGATES THE BODY.
ABOUT BIPARTISAN SHIISN ERA NTI
I ALSO BELVE THAT THE  BIG AND
DARK, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE
OPPOSITION TO THE FILIBUSTER.AN
I IN IT'S PRETTYN
THAT THESE GROUPS EXERLOFLUENCD
AS THEY CAN ON OF
CONGRESS.
LD SCHOOL  ATIHE
ABSO ROL
MAN' I ASK ABOUT WHAT'S
AT TH
THTOENERALK
ON FRIDAY
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENTDEN JUE S
UNDER , GAG ORDERSINST S ANS TH
ARE CONTINUING DEFENDING
ANTI-LGBTQ LAWS, SHIELDI
RUSSNFBLYOU MAKEF ?
>> YEAOU ALLTHE SUITS THOU
JUST MENON, THD.J. DO
PU ARGUING IN
COURT FOR U.S. CITIZENO  IPUAV
LOWER ELIGITR SOCIAL
SECURITY THATHR
COUNTERPARTS, U.ENS IN
ITED STATES.
ESSENTLL ADVANCING SECOND ZENSHG
SECOND CLASS CITIZENSHIP FOR
PUERSLAND.
D.O.J. BEEN NS OF
EXTREMELY CONCERNINGS T JUST ONN
LSO EXTREM, BUACSS
BOARD, I DONELHA
WHATN VOTING RIGHTS IS
APPRECIATED, WEN'T SEEING A ANSN
EEN LOOKING
D THAT IS AT
DESERVES A LOTT TO ABOUT TOP
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE LEADERSND ZEN
NGMAN FR,
FOR AT WAS
A, QUOTEIVE AN
MISGUIDED REMARK THAT THEY SAY
EQD S. AND ISRAEL WITH
ORZASHE LATEIFIED SAYINGHE
WAS NOT DOTHAT.
BU Y- OU
READ WHAT YOU TWEETED IN ONSE.
OMAR CBLARF ILHAN TIRET VILIFICC
THEY HOR THE
DANGER THEY PUR IN BY
SKIPPING PRIATIONS
AND LEAPIN TARGETED
NEW CYCLESROUNFI
D YO FELLOW S SCD U SAYING TRE
ARACTERIZED. H COMMENTS
E ARLYG
AN NAMEDM IN CON S  THESER ACTOT
AFGHANISTAN WITH T UNITED
STATES ANDITH
KNOW, I THIT TO TF ISRAEL.
LIEV
THESTWE WAS
INVESTIGATIONS IN WHL FOUR
IGEDSTANCES  CRIMES,
KNOW, I BELITHIS WAS EQUATINTHES
INTERPRETATION WHATSOEVER.
ANNO TEND TO BTHIS WHOLEUBBUB
STARTED  RIGHT WIN
RIGHT WING VITRIOL.T.ITEGS
SES THAT
TARGET.
AND AS SOMEONE WHO HAS THAT, YOT
THE SCALE AND